a primeras horas del viernes el veterano
de la marina estadounidense Daniel Penny
compareció ante el tribunal penal de
Manhattan se enfrenta ahora un cargo de
homicidio en segundo grado dos semanas
después de retener en una asfixia mortal
a Jordan Lili un artista callejero sin
hogar y con antecedentes de enfermedad
mental ya en el penis entregó
voluntariamente con el tipo de dignidad
de integridad que caracteriza su
historial de servicio a esta agradecida
nación el caso pasará ahora a los
tribunales el primero de mayo en el
metro de Nueva York Daniel puso a Jordan
una llave de estrangulamiento durante
varios minutos los abogados del exmarin
alegaron que actuó para protegerse a sí
mismo y al resto de las personas
presentes en el tren pero el equipo
legal de la familia de jordanelli
subrayo que según los Testigos no había
atacado a ningún pasajero
para todos los que dicen yo he estado en
el tren y he pasado miedo antes y no
puedo decirles lo que habría hecho en
esa situación les voy a decir
pregunten Cómo pueden ayudar
por favor no ataques no estrangules no
mates no le quites a alguien un ser
querido porque está en un mal momento el
homicidio y el retraso de la fiscalía en
acusar a Daniel Penny provocaron
protestas los manifestantes señalan
además que jordanilliera afro y Daniel
peñiz blanco en un país regularmente
marcado por crímenes racistas